as americans celebrate this july fourth
weekend there are concerns that low
vaccination rates in some parts of the
country could lead
to new outbreaks of covid19 only 18
states
have fully vaccinated more than half
their population
and with more contagious delta variant
on the rise there are fears that many
people
remain vulnerable our lead national
correspondent david begno visited
arkansas to learn more about the
disappointing vaccination rate
there it's the lunch rush hour at trio's
restaurant in little rock
hello ladies we went to every single
table
and asked the same question have you
been vaccinated absolutely yes
everybody's in absolutely despite
arkansas's reputation
look that reputation isn't undeserved
only 34.3 percent of arkansas's
population
is fully vaccinated are you vaccinated
and that's why trio's co-owner kathy
peck was shocked when she found out that
every single person in the restaurant
was vaccinated except for one person
before we started this i thought i bet
at least 80 percent of my customers are
vaccinated
i was wrong but arkansas's governor asa
hutchinson says
outside of little rock is where it's a
different story well certainly
the rural areas of our state we have
more resistance
there's less vaccine acceptance pulaski
county which includes little rock
has fully vaccinated about 40 percent of
its residents
but in some of the state's rural
counties that number plummets
to less than 25 percent and covet
hospitalizations are climbing
up nearly 54 percent in just the last
two weeks
and that is due in large part to the
so-called delta variant
which the governor says is spreading
fast here over 98 percent of the
hospitalized patients have not been
vaccinated
but as you see those cases going up and
the risk increasing
then all of a sudden the vax
vaccinations increase
so you're saying as hospitalizations
rise here in arkansas
you're starting to see more people get
vaccinated that's true
and so driven by what fear well i
presume i think it's
driven by risk that they see the risk
increasing
and and say we better go ahead and get
vaccinated and right now the demand for
vaccines
is up on wednesday arkansas recorded
more than 10 000 shots in a single day
and that is the most they've seen since
may for cbs this morning i'm david begno
in the natural state arkansas
yeah i saw a story on the news the other
day guys that the only people who are
still dying from covid19 are people that
have not been vaccinated
i don't know what more we can say to get
people to encourage people to take i
know it's a personal decision i get that
but it's just so important in terms of
saving your life and other people around
you
showing those stories are so important
and even those of people who have said
i was against it i was against it i
think earlier this week there was a
woman
and i think that's the most powerful
thing we can show because everyone has
their reasons and their views
but the more you see it the more likely
you are to go you know what
maybe i should get this changes your
calculations i'm scared of needles but
i'm scared of death more
so well said